professor of neuroscience
anil seth says i wonder given what i
perceive as a long-standing skepticism
of
scientific progress in the understanding
of consciousness
whether chomsky has seen any promising
shift toward
good ideas in this domain
well it's worth thinking about it for a
moment
in recent years consciousness has been
called
the hard problem the real
serious problem of philosophy and
science
we might look at a little bit of history
here
if you go back to the 17th century
there was a hard problem it was motion
motion was what was called the hard rock
in philosophy
philosophy meaning science we can't
comprehend it
uh turns out it was right we couldn't
comprehend it
and we still don't comprehend it not in
the sense in which
galileo leibniz
huygens newton the other
great founders of modern science wanted
to understand things they
for them intelligibility and
understanding
meant constructing a mechanical
model for it and mechanical model
meant something with gears and
levers and uh cranks and so on something
like
what was being produced all over europe
at that time by highly skilled artisans
and were amazing people with their
imitations of
human beings duck digesting
the fountains at versailles and so on
and the what was called the mechanical
philosophy
meaning mechanical science that was the
basis for the scientific revolution held
that the entire world
must be a massive machine of this kind
and there was a problem of explaining
motion within that system that was the
hard rock
then newton came along and said it's
hopeless
a newton's theory
crucially involved forces that
cannot be captured within the mechanical
philosophy
newton didn't believe it he spent the
rest of his life trying to overcome it
he regarded it as an absurdity
that no person of scientific
uh intelligence can possibly accept
uh leibniz others agreed they accused
him of
reintroducing the occult
properties of the despised
neo-scholastics
and he didn't disagree that's why his
principia is a mathematical theory
not a physical theory he was crucial on
that
i don't have a physical explanation i
just have something that works
so we can understand the theory but we
cannot dress what it's talking about
what's important just to keep it brief
is that the
hard rock in philosophy was abandoned
it was recognized that we cannot
comprehend
we can't we cannot gain an intelligible
universe modeled on our that
meets our standards of intelligibility
so it was abandoned and science just
reduced its goals
to finding intelligible theories
i think the same is true of
consciousness of many
and many other things we just abandoned
the search for
unintelligible you universe we try to
find
intelligible theories that will account
for the phenomena
and in that respect there's progress in
understanding consciousness so there are
better theories about some of its
properties and so on
and that's the most that we can aspire
to we're not going to
achieve for this hard problem what we
haven't achieved for other hard problems
it's an illusion it was correct to give
up the
search for an intelligible account of
motion
and move on to develop theories which
explain it
onto relativistic theories and
theories of gravitons or whatever you
like
but we we don't have an intelligible
concept of the universe in the
sense of newton and galileo so i think
the answer to the question about
consciousness is let's
find out more about it and develop some
kind of theoretical account of what it
is
and i think there's quite a lot to say
about that one thing
which we could go into is that almost
everything
in our mental lives is
beyond the reach of consciousness
consciousness
picks up little bits and fragments
of what our mental life is about there's
a lot to say about that but let's go on
to your question